reading your book it was very affecting
how you were in high school when 9/11
happened and you just like we're like oh
my gosh like that the entire perception
of Muslim Americans has been changed by
this event now certainly they're
different in many respects I mean our
everything is different but I will say
that the closest analogue I can think of
to the fact that now Asian Americans are
perceived as responsible for the virus
was in your own experience as a Muslim
American post 9/11 mm-hmm yeah no I am
it is devastating to watch as people who
are doing nothing but trying to protect
themselves and their families from what
we're all trying to protect ourselves
and our families from are now being hit
with the added burden of discrimination
simply as a function of what they look
like and and where their families come
from and yeah I remember being a junior
in high school when 9/11 happened
tonight you know I remember was the
beginning of school year right so you're
still excited about about school
starting and you're just getting into
your groove and for for me you know was
the first time that I went from being no
brown guy with a funny name to being a
very particular kind of brown guy with a
very particular kind of funny name and
then all of a sudden right everybody
sort of knew all of the epithets they
knew all of the stereotypes no for our
family in particular my little brother
who's 8 years younger than I am his name
is Osama oh my gosh wait if you're a
junior in high school that makes you
like 16 years old he's like 80 was a eat
yeah yeah oh no yeah that would have
been brutal brutal I'm sure at some
point he even thought about like maybe I
should like go by another name did you
like adopt another Nick you know to his
credit my parents asked him they said
you know you can go by Sam we'll just
start calling you Sam he said no my name
is Osama that's what you named me and
that's my name and I'm proud of it you
know just it was a it was a sort of a
moment of just being like you know
that's uh it takes a lot for an
eight-year-old who was getting bullied
left and right my brother is also kind
of like your brother he's just one of
those really really good nice people and
his response when he'd get bullied for
his name and of course it's still hot
wasn't to lash out wasn't to hit back
his response almost always was just this
like extremely emotionally mature
response which was you know when you say
that it really hurts my feelings and it
just diffuses everything right people
are just that when they hear that
they're like on I'm sorry man
like I didn't I didn't mean hurt your
feelings it's just so I mean emotionally
mature beyond beyond his years
he said you know I'm not I'm not ashamed
of Who I am and what my name is and and
I'm proud of my name in Arabic it means
lion-hearted and you know in fact my
parents my name my full name is Abdul
Rahman it's 11 letters long and nobody
can say it so I became Abdul before I
started preschool because that was you
know 1989 and Paula Abdul was a thing
and Kareem abdul-jabbar was a thing and
then eight years later they had my
little brother and they're like you know
we got to give him an easier name so
let's just do Sam was on the front and
on the back and so like my parents are
over to on boys names but yeah it was it
went from all of a sudden being
different to being a very particular
kind of different and you knew exactly
what the stereotypes were going to be
and how it was gonna hit you and so you
know my heart goes out to Asian American
folks in our communities who have to
bear this and I'm just deeply sorry and
I'll tell you this whenever and if ever
I see it I want to call it out and I
think all of us should make that
commitment to call it out because it's
wrong it's dangerous and it's hurtful
and it's something we need to always
constantly be doing work to root out in
our societies know when I think about
the people are affected for whatever
reason I just keep thinking about this
Chinese family I met in Iowa where they
just ran like the local Chinese buffet
and they were very very sweet people and
right now I'm sure every restaurant in
that town is closed but I have this
sinking feeling that even after
restaurants reopen that that family's
business is going to be worse than it
was and that that's gonna play out
across China towns around the country
around you know those like ethnic food
Mart's that I personally love whenever I
see like an Asian food market you
probably say wait like probably like
when you see he's like certain I think
food markets we just run in and there's
like goo with it you get like four or
five things from your childhood ever
mind you of that okay like I have this
sinking feeling that all of those busy
are going to suffer because people are
just going to not want to go to that
restaurant that Chinatown that community
that food market and I I think it's
going to persist do you have any tips
for folks who are like new to this you
know I am you know I think I think
certainly people of color in our country
have have experienced this for a long
time and also you know it's important to
call out that Cova 19 had a
disproportionate impact on black
Americans and Native Americans and so
we're seeing structural racism play out
in a number of ways yeah that's
happening right in Michigan right I
think I just saw the stat where
african-americans are 13% of the state
of Michigan but 40% of the death so far
that's right that's right and so you
know I don't know that that I can share
anything that other folks haven't
already experienced or thought through
but what I will say is number one we all
have a choice about where and how we
spend our money and so if you've got an
ethnic Rocher in your community who you
think is going to be in trouble because
of the I hate to say at the xenophobia
and the discrimination in a community
make sure you go spend your buck out
there right that's that's a simple thing
that all of us can do number two I think
you know the impact of this is so much
more disproportionate on young people
because it frames the way that they
think about themselves and I think one
of the most important things that we can
do is make sure that we're constantly
empowering young people who face
discrimination on a daily basis and
reminding them that they're beautiful
that they're meaningful that they matter
that they have power and that we are
proud of them right because that's where
they get their own sense of their pride
and their value and their sense of
belonging and then number three that I
and my life used to respond to a lot of
this by hitting back and I found that
just over time that yeah just so you
know I don't know people I can see you
Abdul right now but a Abdul seems like
pugnacious type terms of like he's like
played football I think in high school
and like that's right yeah like
certainly I could very easily see like
if someone gave you [ __ ] dye school
you'd be like all right let's see I hate
to say it sometimes my fur
reaction but it's never my best reaction
well I think I think part of its just
like where you are you know in terms of
your maturation stage like because I can
imagine high school you would just hit
back immediately
yeah college probably say the same but I
mean at this point you're like a dad
like you've been like the head of the
Department of Health the city of Detroit
you pretty much have to learn to have a
very thick skin at some point the other
thing you start to appreciate is that
people who engage in this form of
behavior oftentimes they do it because
they've given themselves license to try
and take away your humanity and I think
you know if I learned anything my little
brother is that in that response when he
would say you know that hurts my
feelings
what he was doing was very very clearly
asserting his humanity people have
feelings right and if you're able to
look at somebody and say you know what
you said really hurt my feelings it
forces a certain empathy because all of
us have had our feelings hurt and I just
think that there is a space to ask why
are you saying what you're saying and
how can I show you that what you're
saying
actually it defiles you just like it
just like you think it defiles me and if
we can grapple with forcing people to
come to terms with the mutual shared
humanity that all of us have in this
moment I think we're all the better for
it right and then the other thing is one
of the points that my mom used to always
make is that now at some point you can
only control you and you can ask
yourself what did you do in that moment
to bring out the best in someone and
obviously when someone's being racist
and discriminatory they're not their
best and you know some would say well
you know what I don't owe them anything
and that's true you don't but I think
there is always an opportunity to ask
how do I bring my best in a situation
and how do I pull out even the shred of
what's what's good in that person that's
left like all right so I've got an
opportunity to engage someone who's not
being their best and I bring my best to
bring out their best because if you can
do that right that's the kind of person
who truly changes things that constant
ask it's a hard thing to do and
certainly if you don't if you choose not
to do it no harm no foul I don't blame
you but there is a real opportunity
there
that opportunity is worth taking
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]